[Musique]
bonsoir Anthony bonsoir je suis le début
de la guerre en Ukraine c'est une
théorie récurrente sur les réseaux
sociaux le conflit ne serait qu'une mise
en scène encore un exemple ce soir avec
deux vidéos d'un homme en uniforme
militaire oui depuis plusieurs jours
plusieurs comptes essentiellement au
prorus que ce soit sur Twitter ou
Facebook partage de séquences que l'on
va découvrir ensemble d'abord cet homme
en uniforme militaire
ukrainien vous l'entendez il y a un fond
musical sur ces images il est filmé il
déambule dans la forêt avec le regard on
ne peut plus menaçant voilà pour la
première séquence pour ce qui est de la
deuxième on retrouve ce même homme cette
fois à genoux et qui se tient la tête
dans dans les bras et qui semble gémir
de douleur et vous aurez remarqué que là
encore il est filmé alors ces deux
vidéos seraient donc deux nouvelles
preuves du d'une mise en scène du
conflit en Ukraine qui dure depuis
février tout est faux nous dit par
exemple cette internaute en anglais
leur revendications sont fausses leur
récit également ou cette autre
internaute cette fois en allemand qui
nous dit vraisemblablement le prochain
tournage de La fake news de la prochaine
fake news est en cours alors qui est cet
homme en vérité et bien pour répondre à
cette question on va prendre deux
captures d'écran des deux vidéos que je
vous ai montré parce que il y a un
indice pour savoir qui est l'homme que
l'on voit les deux captures d'écran les
voici je voulais remémore et l'indice il
se trouve ici regardez avec vous aurez
reconnu le logo du réseau social Tik Tok
mais surtout ce nom d'utilisateur que
l'on retrouve également ici et pour
cause parce que lorsque vous vous rendez
sur Tik Tok et vous que vous tapez
pardon le nom d'utilisateur en question
vous tombez sur ce compte qui vous le
voyez à plusieurs vidéos dont
les deux qui nous occupent ce soir mais
la réponse elle va venir d'une autre
vidéo en l'occurrence celle-ci pourquoi
parce que dans cette vidéo il y a en
fait un commentaire qui va nous
intéresser ici il est en ukrainien je
vous l'ai traduit et on apprend que cet
homme est un acteur il s'agit de Petro
Pavlovic chez rekking et lorsque l'on va
cette fois taper son nom sur Google son
nom en ukrainien je précise et bien on
va tomber sur plusieurs sites notamment
en russe consacrés au cinéma dans
lesquels il est mentionné c'est le cas
par exemple ici donc voilà pour ces
citrus qui parlent de cinéma et dans
lesquels il est mentionné mais ils ont
tout aussi sur une chaîne YouTube à son
nom et notamment plus particulièrement
cette vidéo qui date du 14 octobre 2022
donc très récente et qui vous le voyez
dans son intitulé faire référence un
clip de chanteuse ukrainienne Anna
canina alors on retrouve aussi dans
cette vidéo qui semble qui qui est censé
montrer les coulisses du tournage de ce
clip on retrouve plusieurs éléments
visuels qui vont coïncider avec d'autres
éléments visuels que l'on retrouve dans
les séquences virales que je vous ai
montré au début de cette chronique ce
qui laisse donc penser très probablement
que les deux scènes ont été tournées
dans le même contexte alors Arthur
Bahamas de la rédaction des Observateurs
de France 24 a contacté l'acteur en
question il nous explique qu'il est
qu'il joue le rôle d'un soldat donc on
l'aura compris qui va à la recherche de
sa femme et de son enfant à travers la
gare et il explique justement les
coulisses du tournage je vous invite à
écouter ou à lire les sous-titres plus
précisément
[Musique]
l'acteur qui a par ailleurs confié aux
observateurs de France 24 qu'il avait
été assez étonné de voir cet épisode
utilisé à des fins de fake news
justement et France 24 a également
contacté la chanteuse ukrainienne qui
confirme la version de l'acteur
effectivement Anna Kahina donc que l'on
voit ici des propos recueilli cette fois
par Alice qui nomade elle confie elle
confirme pardon que ses plans sont bien
issus du de son du tournage de son clip
et en l'occurrence de son titre berceuse
c'est son nom titre qui est sorti le 6
octobre dernier le clip lui est en cours
de finalisation une chanson nourrie par
son expérience personnelle puisque elle
a vécu les bombardements elle a dû
laisser aussi son mari partir alors
pourquoi y a-t-il un soldat dans ce clip
et bien elle nous l'explique tout
simplement parce que cette chanson est
censée montrer la douleur de la guerre
alors pour tous les Ukrainiens hommes et
femmes mais plus particulièrement pour
ces femmes et ses enfants qui attendent
leur père leur frère leur mari qui
doivent donc revenir de la guerre alors
l'infox ce soir et bien c'est un exemple
de plus de désinformation de toute cette
théorie liée à la mise en scène supposée
de la guerre en Ukraine souvenez-vous
Marion c'était sur ce plateau même la
semaine dernière je vous parlais de faux
blessés à Kiev mais il y a quelques
temps il y avait aussi cette histoire de
faux reportage de la BBC ou même de faux
crime de guerre mise en scène là encore
trois exemples trois infos que je vous
invite à consulter sur le site des
Observateurs de France 24 pour voir leur
déconstruction merci beaucoup Anthony
Saint-Léger